the polystyrene clam-shaped burger box
among the most common packaging in our
takeaways
and one of the items the public wants to
see banned the most
but it is not on the list of things
being considered for a ban as the
government ramps up its war on plastic
waste
i'd say certain types of plastic
containers are more durable
and
the polystyrene containers they're quite
good to be fair it's very sturdy to help
stop spillages as much as well
i'm gonna do a dish curry goat rice and
peas
neo's takeaway in manchester gives away
300 of these a day like to load up for
the customers
until they and others can move to more
sustainable alternatives the pile of
plastic waste will just keep rising
the government is considering banning
plastic plates cups and cutlery but
according to the definition in the
consultation containers with lids aren't
plates so that means they don't fall
under the scope of a ban
that means we could see a move away from
plastic plates and trays to more of
these
critics say england is already playing
catch-up behind scotland and wales when
it comes to tackling the problem and
that the current list just isn't enough
it needs to be looking at very ambitious
measures like legally binding targets to
half plastic production by 2025 and the
upcoming environment build provides the
opportunity to do just that it could
also look at banning waste exports so
the plastic we are producing isn't
causing harm elsewhere
the uk government has already taken
major steps to address the issue like
reducing the number of plastic bags in
use and limiting the supply of
single-use plastic straws
it promises to prevent all avoidable
plastic waste by 2043
but with so many harmful alternatives
still on the market
there's a long way to go sadia chowdhury
sky news in manchester